*** Music ***
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hi!
Hi everyone!
Hello!
Hi!
Hi everyone!
Hello!
Hi!
Let me shrink us down a little bit.
We're playing Don't Starve!
Together!
And as you can see,
I'm a ghost and I already died
and we didn't even start playing the game.
Yeah.
We both don't know how to play this game.
Both of us don't know how.
Well, I see knows a little bit you said, right?
Yeah, no.
I didn't play this game
in literally like years
so I barely remember anything at all.
Okay.
Well, barely anything is...
You have to figure it out!
Barely anything is more than nothing.
So how do I go back?
Okay, close. I'm still alive. Hello!
Exam and I see...
Hello!
Wait, you're...
Treat?
With a treat?
How do I get a treat?
Chat, if you want to backseat us,
please do it!
Walk to skill...
Wow, well...
Did it say she will live in Valhalla?
Oh.
Well, that's great.
Do you want to restart the game?
Yes, let's restart.
Okay!
Oh, my God!
Best collab.
You started the collab already dead.
Unless anyone knows how to...
Unless anyone knows how to revive.
I think you revive going to the door.
Oh!
Can you walk into the door?
Oh, let me see.
Um...
Did it do anything?
Oh?
Okay.
Um, give me nothing.
It takes a lot to revive another player this early.
Okay, well, let's restart then.
Yeah, let's just...
Let's just restart.
I'm going to disconnect, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I leave?
What do I do? Disconnect?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to delete the world
that we just played in.
Um...
Okay.
I actually don't know how to do that,
so I'm just going to create another one.
Yeah, and then just invite me
the same way you did earlier.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, good.
I'm going to put the same password, okay?
Okay, okay, okay.
Um...
Friends only.
Okay. Generate world.
We're off to a great start.
Yes.
We jumped into the game a little early.
Yeah, just a little.
No one can even hear the music on my side.
Really?
Yeah.
Can you hear it on my side?
I don't know.
I can open your stream.
I was too lazy to
separate the audio.
I'm not good at separating audios.
I'm not...
I'm actually not separating it.
Oh.
I'm not separating mine.
It's the audio.
I'm really bad at like
making sure that you're loud enough
while also having the game loud enough.
Mmm.
So I have to separate it, but I don't know how to separate the game.
Oh, okay.
We can hear the opening of the music.
Yeah, you hear it.
Okay. They hear it on my side.
Okay.
Let me invite you.
Close the buttons.
Shift tap.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay!
Okay, let me
do this.
There we go.
It's like Terraria.
Like Minecraft.
Okay.
I've played Terraria in Minecraft.
Have you?
You basically...
Me? Yeah, I've played here and there.
Okay, so we should be good.
Basically,
from what I remember, you need to
like, you know,
craft stuff and like
find things to
survive, basically.
And during the night,
you need to make sure that you have fire, I think,
so that,
you know, you don't
die like me.
Okay, okay.
Let's go, let's go.
Okay, I'm going to pick some flowers.
I don't know if that's going to be useful, probably not.
Let me get some saplings.
Maybe we need those.
Fuck.
I think, yeah, saplings are good
to build a fire, right?
I think.
Me too.
Okay, I'm getting some seeds.
Should I not touch that beehive?
Or should I touch it?
I probably
wouldn't, just in case.
Okay.
Unless you're a big...
I found some berries.
That will keep us from being hungry.
The music is too loud for me again.
Off, zero.
Okay, there.
Yes.
Why is the game music still on?
I don't know.
Oh, ambient volume, that's why.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, I found a carrot.
I found a carrot.
Pick it, pick it. Can I...
Oh, there's a bee. Careful, will it sting you?
I don't know.
Oh, did it just go away?
No, it's on the floor. It's got legs.
Oh.
Okay.
Find stones so you can make a...
I can't read.
Oh, tools, tools.
Oh, we need stone.
Okay, hello.
Any stones in chat?
Any stoneers?
Oh, I'm going to pick up the carrot.
Well, there's a lot of food here
and we need food to survive.
And maybe you can find some...
Oh, I found some flint.
Is that what they mean?
Maybe.
Anything in here? No, no.
Oh, here's more flint.
Nice.
Where did I get meat from?
We probably need to make a tool
to hunt.
Do we need a crafting table in Minecraft?
Um...
Tools.
Oh, I think...
I think...
On the left side at the top...
Mm-hmm.
Uh...
If you see, like, we can
craft because we have twigs.
I crafted myself an axe.
On the left side, there's, like,
different tools and you can see
if you have enough to craft.
So now I have an axe.
Okay, I'll get an...
And I can attack.
I can attack.
Kill the bee!
Okay, never mind.
Mistakes were made.
Oh, fuck.
Can we kill them?
Can we kill...
I'm just going to run away.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, I just crafted
a...
Nice!
Cool!
We can chop trees now.
What do we need?
We need grass in order to make
a fire...
a torch, I think.
So let me get some grass.
Oh, I see the torch.
Yeah.
Like, if you click on the
very thing on the very top
of the left, like, slide thing,
if you click
light sources, you can
either make a campfire
or a torch.
I'm making a torch right now.
Okay.
I should have
enough to make a campfire soon.
Now we're surviving.
Now we're mining
and crafting.
Oh, it's getting dark!
Oh, it's getting dark.
You have coming towards you.
Okay, how do I...
How do I...
There's the campfire!
We're safe.
Okay, we're going to be okay.
We're going to be okay tonight.
I'm going to get more wood.
How did you
put down the campfire?
I just clicked on the button
and then placed it down on the floor.
Hmm.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I see.
I see.
I'm going to get...
You should be able to.
Can I kill the birds?
You can try.
Attack! Attack! Attack!
Damn it.
You can meet with it.
Hmm, let me see.
People are talking about
hounds.
Hounds?
What about them?
That they're coming.
We'll be fine.
I'm not worried.
I'm a bear.
You have me by your side.
I'll maul them and fight them off.
Okay.
Apparently, I need to
feed the fire.
At fuel.
Oh, the gloom and croaches.
Oh, that's so scary.
Why does your character say such
scary things?
Because of my mental illness.
Oh, my God.
What's this thing? It's a butterfly.
Is it?
Yeah.
Can I kill the bird?
I'm trying to kill the butterfly.
It won't let me attack the butterfly.
I wonder what we could
even do with a butterfly, to be honest.
Eat it.
I'm pretty confident in our
so I think we're doing really good right now.
I mean, so far.
Yeah.
Should we release the hands?
There's hands in this game?
A what?
Someone said, should we warn them
about the hands?
What do they mean the hands?
What hands?
Is there hands in this game?
This game got hands?
What do they mean by that?
I'm too stupid
to understand.
What hands?
Wait, my character only eats meat?
Oh, no!
Really?
How is I supposed to know
that when choosing the character?
Oh, no!
How much is your hunger?
It's a 56.
56?
Minus 85!
Oh, no!
How do I add to the fire?
You have to have logs, I think.
Or maybe we can add to other stuff.
Can I add a pine cone?
Or you can add other stuff.
How do I...
I'm adding fuel.
Did I make the fire too early?
I don't think so.
I mean, you picked one of the hardest
characters in the game.
Oh, no!
I picked the character
that looks like me.
Why are the sides of my screen
going weird?
Is it because...
I think it's because I ate.
As soon as I ate, it did that.
Like, look.
Oh, wait. Never mind.
Maybe it's not because I ate.
You're overheating?
Me eating here
while you're fucking starving and dying.
It's because you're near the fire.
Okay.
It's getting lighter.
I'm going to try and find you some meat.
I have four meat in my inventory.
Can I cook it?
Where did you find meat?
It came with me
when I spawned, I think.
Oh!
Well, that meat is going to run out.
Should I eat?
When's a good time to kill the creatures?
Don't cook.
Don't cook. Oh, they spoiled?
Bro, this game is so hard.
We can do it.
We can do it. I believe
we are smart
young ladies.
We're smart.
Independent young women.
Yeah.
We can make this on our own.
You can kill Icy for me.
What are you doing?
Watch out, Icy.
Don't fall asleep near me.
Oh, no.
I'm not supposed to eat you.
What the fuck?
Now I feel even more pressure
trying to find meat for you.
Jesus Christ.
Find me food or else I'll eat you.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Can I replant the trees?
I feel like I've been
Oh, no.
Oh, fuck.
Can I eat the mushrooms?
I don't know.
Can you?
There's a chicken.
I'm screaming.
I'm fighting.
I'm dying.
I'm coming.
I'm attacking them.
How do I attack them?
Oh, now they're attacking me.
I can't attack them?
You should be able to.
Fuck you.
Where's my health?
I'm okay.
Oh, fuck.
My health is so low.
My health is literally 19.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I'm coming to get the frog.
Where is it?
The frog fights back.
Is this food?
Oh, I found a spear.
Froglet.
I think we should kill that chicken.
The turkey.
The turkey, yeah.
No, it's too fast.
Come here.
What is it doing?
Come on.
Let's get it.
Yes.
Get the other jumpsick.
You take it.
You need me to survive.
I can survive on other stuff.
Like carrots and berries and stuff.
You can be the vegan.
Vegan bear.
What the fuck?
And a polar bear.
That was supposed to be the most vicious bear.
Help.
Someone said
anytime you're not full
is a good time to eat on your character.
Oh.
We have to replant the trees, apparently, too.
Really?
Yeah.
How do I
regain my health?
I need to craft bandages or something.
How do I replant trees, too?
Form two weapons
aren't clothing healing.
Oh, it's going to fall.
Fuck.
Ashes, rocks, spider gland.
Spider gland.
Oh, shit.
I don't have the stuff to make a campfire.
Rope. How do I make a rope?
Why is there a path here?
Oh, fuck.
I don't know.
Do you have leaves?
Do you have grass?
I think.
Let me see.
It's going around cooking it.
Petals.
Cut grass. Yeah, I have that.
Can you give it to me?
Yeah.
I dropped it.
I can make a campfire.
I'll wait a little longer, I think.
I think I should wait a little longer.
Don't wait until it's pitch black.
Okay.
Nothing.
I really need to get some healing.
I am on 19 health.
How do you?
I need grass and rope.
Oh, okay.
How do I make rope, though?
How do I give you some of the grass?
You drag it, I guess.
I make rope
with cut grass.
Okay, here. Take the cut grass back
so you can make rope.
Okay, let me see.
Okay, so...
One...
Don't use all of it, though, because we need it for a campfire.
No, is this...
I don't know how to...
Huh.
What do you mean? Well, how am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to heal then?
No.
Help us!
Snowberries, pin pals, please.
You need to craft a science machine.
You have to unlock TAC in the menu.
Don't stop to get this weird.
Oh, that is fucking shit.
What the fuck?
Lysors, prototypes, and stations?
Oh, science machine.
We need a gold nugget
and four rocks and four logs
to make a science machine.
Where in the fuck am I gonna find
a fucking golden nugget?
Come on.
Jesus Christ.
Well, how do I make healing items?
That's so stupid.
Where do we find gold nuggets from rocks?
Turn on your flower thingy for the ghost...
Ghosts? There's ghosts in this game?
Yeah.
Oh, I think...
There was a pickaxe, right?
So we have to... we can make a pickaxe
and mine the rocks, probably.
Okay, let's look for more flints and sticks.
Oh, maybe I should make one.
Oh, fuck.
How do I get out of this screen?
What?
Fuck.
Oh, God.
You scared me.
I'm sorry.
Help.
Oh, my God.
I was trying to, like, pick up my torch
because I got so scared and nervous
I forgot where it is
and where to click.
Oh, my God.
There's eyes in the darkness.
It's okay.
They will not hurt us.
Can I cook the mushroom?
I can.
What the fuck?
I don't think I can eat it. Here, have the cooked mushroom.
Here you go.
Oh.
Did it just suddenly get dark for you?
I mean, get light for you.
It's bright.
Yeah, it's bright for me.
How did that happen?
I don't...
Wait, I don't...
What the fuck?
I only have four health.
Oh, shit.
Did the mushroom take away
my health?
Oh, no.
Did the mushroom hurt you?
I don't know.
I'm not gonna eat it.
My health went to, like, four.
Oh, fuck.
I'm going to need seeds.
There is...
Oh.
Oh, God.
Um...
Okay, okay, let's focus on...
Okay, I need...
We need Flinton and Twigs to make a pickaxe
so that we can get...
So that we can make the science station.
Yeah.
Here's... Okay, Twigs.
Okay.
Do you get Twigs from the saplings?
Yeah, yeah, you do.
Okay.
I'm gonna get rid of the green cap mushroom.
I don't trust it.
Go away, mushroom.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
You didn't know.
Well, here's more Twigs.
I'm so scared of dying, honestly.
My health is so fucking low.
It's okay, we'll get that station.
We'll get that station.
We'll get it, we'll get it.
I just... I need a Flint.
I can't find any anywhere.
Yeah.
I don't see, like, a lot of Flint.
Cooked green mushrooms are minimally poisonous,
but restore sanity.
Oh, oopsies.
Shit.
Where's all the stones?
Oh, there. What is this?
Charcoal. Oh, fuck, that's not what we want.
That's not what we want.
Can I go in the water?
No.
I don't know. I tried going in the water,
but I didn't...
There's a monster in the water!
With seven health left,
I don't think I should be going there.
Personally.
Press M to bring up a map if you get lost.
Oh!
That's helpful.
Does this say...
Oh, it shows where everything is.
Is that a gravestone?
Or is that rocks?
I don't know.
If they chose the base characters,
would it have been easier?
Well, I wanted to choose a character that looks like me.
Yeah, exactly.
I wanted to choose cute character.
Yeah.
Who cares if it makes the game harder?
At least I'm pretty.
Yes.
Exactly. That's how I feel about games.
As long as I can look pretty,
that's all that matters.
Oh, there's an animal track.
There's a gravestone here.
Where?
Press M.
I realized some guy.
Are there treasures?
Why do I not see on the map?
Oh, shit.
We're too far away from each other.
Maybe we should go back to each other.
Um...
Wait, is that Flint?
Oh, no.
No, no.
Oh, I see you.
Come on.
We're here.
I need me.
Come on.
What are these things?
I don't know, but it looks like
it could be meat.
I need to heal really badly.
Fuck.
I'm your bitch.
Why did you say you're my bitch?
Come on.
You need to make traps to bait them into.
It means hungry.
Oh, fuck.
I'll eat.
Here, come.
I'll give you the food that I have
that isn't...
that isn't meat.
Can you eat seeds?
Yeah, but I don't think seeds
makes my health go up.
How do I drop stuff?
I still have 7 health.
Can you eat pine cones?
Oh, I can plant the pine cones.
Oh.
Oh, that's how we replant them.
Oh, okay.
That's good to know.
Okay.
Do you have stuff to make a...
Um...
Do you have stuff to make a campfire?
Let me see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Should I put one right now?
No, wait until it gets a little darker.
Okay, let me know when to put it down.
Okay.
Can't cross river without a boat.
Man, this game is like...
This game is Minecraft on hard mode.
Is this...
Is this a rock?
Is it?
Abigail's flower.
Are you Abigail?
Am I?
Who's Abigail?
Literally who?
Oh, there's more flowers over here.
Okay, okay.
And there's a carrot up there.
Oh, thank god.
And there's carpet on the floor?
Is this carpet?
Marble tree?
Do you see this?
What is this?
I don't know.
Give the flower to Hershey.
Can you use the flower to do something?
Here's Abigail's flower.
Oh, no.
What do I do with a flower?
Oh, there's another monster over here.
Oh, no, it's gone.
Oh!
Abigail!
It's a ghost!
What do you desire, Apparition?
That's my twin sister.
Cool!
Will I protect you?
Okay, okay, get the fire, get the fire, get the fire!
Where's the campfire?
Come on.
Give me campfire.
Oh, fuck!
I'll protect you.
Where's your items? Can I pick up your items?
Okay, let me try to pick up your items so that I can build a campfire.
Oh, my god.
Fuck my life.
I can't see anything.
Oh, god.
What happens if I go towards these eyes around me?
Let me see.
And the curtain falls.
Nothing happens when I walk towards the eyes.
Oh, I get hurt. Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Let's see who's keeping Amy alive.
Yeah, probably. My sanity is at 20, though.
I think we should restart the game.
Let's just go back into your body.
No.
I was playing, I was hunting a fucking torch.
Apparently.
You can hunt items?
I don't know.
How do I hunt a...
survive?
Okay.
Should we restart the game?
Do you want to?
Should we?
Well, I don't think I'll be able to bring you back to life.
Okay, let's try it again.
And I'll try to be more careful
with my health this time.
And not fight
freaking frogs.
Okay, okay.
I'm getting attacked by my own sanity right now.
That's too real.
The demons are actually attacking me right now.
And I'm fighting them back with my axe.
I can see that.
Okay, I'm going to disconnect.
Okay, okay, okay.
Me too.
Damn it.
A touchstone.
It's okay. We'll do better.
We'll do better.
I'm going to be extra careful.
That was a test run.
Yeah, that was just a test run.
We can do so much better.
I believe.
Okay.
Okay, a host game.
Another world.
Should I try relaxed?
Or is that too easy?
I feel like that would be too easy, right?
Yeah, we need a
we need a
challenge.
Yeah, we need a challenge.
We need to prove to everyone how powerful we are.
Okay.
Generate world.
I'll choose a different character this time.
I'll choose one that's easier.
Okay.
And I'm making a sandwich.
Mm-hmm.
What sandwich are you eating?
Um...
Hungarian salami
with Havarti cheese on bread.
Mm, that sounds good.
It is good.
Sounds better than the seeds I was eating.
I'm eating, like, high quality meat.
I'm eating the seeds.
And I'm the fucking bear.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Lumberjack has an axe that can't break and eats wood.
I always liked him.
He sounds like a character, but I don't want to play as an ugly lumberjack.
Okay, that's too real.
I want to play as a cute girl.
That's me in all video games.
Actually, you know, like, when I was a kid
and I just started, like,
getting to, like, know stuff about video games
and all of that stuff.
Mm-hmm.
I completely refused to play any video games as a kid.
The main character wasn't a girl.
I completely refused playing the video game.
I was like,
I'm not playing as a guy.
If I'm playing a video game,
it has to be with a girl character.
Otherwise, I completely refused to play it.
How can I be immersed
if it's not a girl character?
Real and true, I agree.
I kind of did the same thing,
like with Mario Kart and stuff.
Like, I would play the cute girl characters.
Aw, that's really cute.
I might as well just meet you.
Okay, I'm going to join.
Okay.
Someone said the spider is cool.
I can play as a spider?
Wait! I want to play as a spider.
Yeah, Weber.
Oh.
I didn't know that.
Well, that was the best story character
because she has a lighter.
Okay, well, the spider is cool.
Okay.
Does the spider have
good cool powers?
Males in my video game?
Hell no!
Spider won't eat veggies.
Spiders will help you.
Spiders will attack him.
That's it!
Maybe I shouldn't...
You can eat monster meat.
Okay.
I actually think the character I picked now
should work better
because I can actually equip like a teddy bear.
You choose Willow?
Yeah, like, I can have like a teddy bear with me,
which is perfect because it's like
I have a plushie over Snow Berry
with me to protect me.
That would be cute.
Cute, look!
It's you, Snow Berry!
Okay, I'm going to choose Wilson
just because he's the other starter character.
Are you sure? I mean, you can still pick
whoever you want.
No, it's okay. I want to actually be able to survive.
Okay.
Oh, look at this thing!
You has meat?
No.
They can't treat me.
Oh, what's this?
Plugged sinkhole.
Oh, god, now the frogs go away.
What?
Let me pick berries.
How do I get out of the screen? What?
What screen?
I'm stuck in the...
the like, menu.
Really?
What the heck?
Oh, tab? Oh, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
I wonder if that rock...
Okay, I'm going to try real quickly, pick up everything I can
before it gets dark.
There's a pig house.
Oh, go away!
Oh, my god, I have PTSD from the frogs now.
I can never look the same at them.
What happened?
Where are you?
I jumped in a wormhole.
Did you die?
No, I'm alive. I came out the other end.
Okay, I'm going to jump in as well.
Where am I?
I don't know.
But I need to be around you here. I'm here.
Okay, thank you.
There's a negative sanity but teleportation.
Check the map.
That's cool.
Oh, it brought us like, kind of far away.
Maybe we could like, jump back in it
when we want to go back to the other area.
That would be pretty useful.
Yeah, that is useful. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, that's cool.
And my sanity is good. I have high sanity.
Look at that.
Yeah, my sanity is pretty good as well.
Yeah, look at that big-ass head.
That's where I store all my sanity.
That's exactly why I need to take
my retard medication.
Because my brain gets so big
and swollen.
I need a medication to stop the swelling.
Otherwise, my head will explode.
Your brain just can't handle
all of your sanity.
Yeah, my brain is too powerful
for its own good.
Oh, Flint!
Flint!
Oh my god.
Will the bee get mad at me
if I pick the salmon bee?
That bee or not the bee?
Okay, let me get
an axe.
An axe.
A torch.
Ah!
What happened?
I'm getting chased by bees!
Oh no!
I did nothing, though.
Let me equip a torch.
Maybe that will help.
I don't know, but maybe.
Okay, I think they stopped.
They stopped.
Oh, I just noticed
that there's a clock
at the top of the screen.
I didn't see that before.
It shows what time it is.
Okay.
Why is there
road
paths on the floor?
Why?
Where?
Like...
Torchier.
Oh, I think
if I just get close to that bee thing,
they automatically just come running to me.
I'm going to equip the torch
just in case.
Okay, thank you.
Do you have enough to make a campfire?
Um, no.
But I'll make an axe
so that I can get wood for a campfire.
Okay.
Paths make you move faster.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay.
I have a good feeling about this.
Yeah, I think we're going to be okay.
I can actually eat stuff
other than meat this time.
Yeah, and I'll be extra careful
with my health and not fight
army of frogs.
Can I...
I can't plant seeds.
Okay.
Wendy is immune to fire.
What?
I guess you can sit on the campfire if you want.
Really?
Birch.
Oh, space
to pick up the nearest thing.
I've been clicking on everything.
Oh, space?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Wait, waiting for Icy to accidentally start a forest fire?
Icy, start a forest fire.
Should I?
Okay.
Get really close to the tree.
Here you go.
Oh, you get sanity by burning things.
That's cool.
It's not going to spread, is it?
Oh, that's fire!
Oh, no!
That's fire!
No!
Oh, no!
Oh, fuck!
Aren't you... I thought you were immune to fire.
Oh, wait.
I wasn't on fire.
Oh, no, the fire is spreading.
Okay, so...
Never mind, the fire is spreading.
It's only a little bit.
It will be fine.
It gives us lots of light.
Yeah.
We won't even need a campfire,
because we can just...
Oh, there's charcoal.
Yeah, light's everything on fire.
Yeah.
And it gave us charcoal, too.
I'm so smart!
Yes, you are!
Let's go!
Whoa!
Here, I'll light more things on fire.
Awesome!
That was so fun.
I love lighting things on fire.
It's all leafy.
Light it!
Nice.
And light this one, too.
Nice!
Yeah, charcoal is good for fuel.
That's my hunger, I like.
Good.
Oh, I actually have a lighter.
I didn't realize that.
The torch has duration.
Oh.
How do I...
Oh, I see the 40%.
Okay.
Oh, now I'm getting too hot.
And the staff, I can...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, God.
I can't fire. I can't fire.
I'll make one, I'll make one.
Hold on. Oh, I can't.
I don't have enough. I did it.
Okay.
And then maybe feed it.
It's okay.
There we go.
I didn't even have to make a campfire.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we're fine.
It's daylight again.
We're good.
Can I take it back?
I don't think so.
I doubt it.
Okay.
What do I do with the pedal?
Oh, wait.
We should build a science machine, right?
What stuff do we need for it again?
We need to get gold.
Where the fuck am I going to find gold?
Uh, dig in your nose.
Okay.
Twigs and flints to build a pickaxe.
Twigs and flints.
Okay, okay.
I'll look for twigs and flints.
Gold is from rocks.
Got it.
This is going to give me a twig, right?
We need to explore and find a biome with rocks.
They are rocks with gold vein.
Okay, okay, okay.
Pick your nose.
I don't think I found gold yet in my nose.
I'm sorry.
I don't think I have any.
Oh, what happened here?
Examined skeleton.
I found a dead body.
Ooh.
Let me see.
It's just sitting there. I took his loot.
I looted his body.
Is that big bro?
Imagine.
Oh, there's flints on the other side of this.
Oh, there's flints here as well.
You got it? Okay, good.
If you don't need it, I could just give it to you.
Okay.
Give me the flint and I'll make a pickaxe.
And then I guess try to find
a rock.
I wonder if I can make a pickaxe
and use it to
get this thing.
Yeah, I can!
I can mine this rock!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Which rock, though? Hold on.
Oh, no. I don't have enough.
Enough what?
Come here. Take all the stuff if you can.
Oh, no. I don't have enough either.
Fuck, let me eat.
Let me pick this up.
Okay, I picked it up.
I picked it up.
I don't think any of that was gold though, right?
Okay, let's keep looking.
I have
knee tray, but that's not
gold.
Do you want to try to jump back
through the
through the mouth
of the wormhole?
Yeah, let's go.
Let's see what we can find there.
Because we didn't explore in that area.
You know where it is.
Yeah.
Probably
somewhere down.
Yeah, somewhere down.
I have a feeling it was
somewhere in this direction.
Because there was a giant rock
right near
Spallon.
Yeah, I would love to mine.
Like if you see any big rocks.
Oh, the bees are down there.
Oh, fuck.
Whirl.
Well, I probably
need a shovel.
Where's the wormhole? Do you guys
remember?
Oh, fuck.
I don't see it on the map. I'm exploring
new parts of the map. Oh wait, rocks!
Rocks with gold! Here!
Yes! Yes! Get it!
Let's go! Let's go!
It looks like there's gold.
We're gonna make it.
The wormhole!
There it is!
Gold!
I don't have anything.
I don't have the space in my inventory.
Let me eat stuff.
Oh, fuck.
Let me eat all of my fucking berries.
Come on, bitch, eat.
Eat.
Give me fucking gold.
Yes!
Okay, okay.
Okay, more flints.
Hell yeah.
More rocks.
We can build a science machine.
We can.
Yeah, I'm gonna make one, okay?
Okay.
Should I just place it down here?
Yeah, if you want to.
I wonder if we can move it or not.
I did it.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Put the science machine where you want to stay.
Well, I guess we're staying here.
Yeah.
I guess we're staying here.
Fuck! I don't have enough space.
We can make a backpack.
I need two more cut grass
to make a backpack.
Let me see.
I have five.
I have five grass.
Cut grass.
Okay.
I think I can only make one backpack.
Here.
Where is it?
Did I not make it?
Red cap.
Where'd the backpack go?
Oh, here it is.
There it is. Take the backpack.
You're sure? What about you?
It's okay. It's easy to make a backpack.
I just need...
Oops.
I can get the sticks.
Okay.
It's easy to make a backpack.
Okay, I'm going to get some stuff.
Get some more grass.
I guess we need more.
Me too.
We're doing so much better!
I know! We are!
And I feel like this map
that got generated
is so much better too.
Oh, I found more rocks I can mine.
Awesome!
More cold.
Someone said I have a feeling
something's going to blow up.
No.
Well, whoever said that,
you feel wrong.
Your feelings are wrong.
Oh, shit. It's getting dark.
Your feelings are invalid.
Okay, whoa!
Oh, shit!
Where are you?
Oh, dude. Oh, should I build a campfire?
Yeah,
I can build a campfire.
No, I'm getting hurt.
Okay, I'm building it right now.
I'm over here.
Okay, I'm on my way.
I forgot that torch is existed,
to be honest, but it's okay.
You want to come after me?
Yes.
Let's just stay until night is done.
And then
I got hurt.
My health is at 48.
Oh, no.
Because of the dark?
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot about torches existing.
It's okay, it's okay.
At least it's not like 5 or 6 health,
like mine was.
We can still work with that
amount of health and probably
put it back up.
I believe.
Someone said flowers heal.
Really?
They heal very little.
They heal like 1 health.
That's good to know though.
I didn't know.
Yeah, it's like 1, I think.
But thank you for telling me.
Yeah, okay.
That's good to know.
I'm going back up to mine all the stuff.
Okay, I'm
I'm a miner.
Woo!
That's mine.
I need 2 more sticks.
I can't.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Okay, I'm going to go get more sticks
so I can also make a backpack.
Okay.
And then we'll start making traps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need to make another pickaxe
because I'm out of mine.
Okay.
Thank you for all the bless yous
in chat.
Oops.
Woo!
Let's go!
I'm having so much fun now that we're
getting more used to it
and quite to do.
There's so much stuff to mine here.
Okay, this is the perfect area.
We can get so much flint
from this area. It's perfect for us.
Yippee!
I found a...
I'm calling it a chicken. What is it called?
A turkey?
A turkey!
We should kill a turkey
so we can get meat from it.
We'll get back to him.
Where is...
Oh, shoot.
I'm lost.
I think I'm lost.
Oh, no.
Are you?
Don't walk too far.
The science machine can be our home.
Turkeys will eat all the berries?
What the hell?
Kill those turkeys.
Those berries are ours.
Why...
Why is everything in this game against us?
Even the butterflies are against us.
Even the...
I would not be surprised.
Even the fucking butterflies hate us.
It's so...
I'm very happy about this place.
There's so much to mine here.
This will be very useful for us.
Uh-huh.
Flig!
I have literally 16 flint.
That's gotta be useful.
Hopefully.
Yeah, I hope.
Oh, this bunny's got glowing eyes.
Or do they all have glowing eyes?
I have no idea.
I'll go back.
To make a backpack.
Why do I have a gift?
This requires more science.
Oh, never mind.
I'll start science and...
Come on!
Why is this fucking mining?
Okay.
Good.
I thought you were a miner.
I am!
So you should be able to mine.
But sometimes I click it and it doesn't do anything.
But it's fine.
I think it's just the angle I'm doing it at.
No.
Yay!
I have 11 gold.
Nice!
I have 35 rocks.
17 flint.
And 11
golden nuggets.
Let's go.
I love my little miner, I see.
Oh, I found ice!
That's crazy.
Lick it.
I think we should go back to the science station.
Whoa, there's like huge birds here.
Really?
Yeah.
Can we kill them?
I don't know, but they're big.
And I'm lost.
Oh, no, where are you?
I'm trying to find the science station again.
Oh.
Oh, God.
Fuck, I don't know where you are.
The science station is basically...
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Come back to the science station.
Okay.
I'm on my way.
And I'll build...
I'll make a backpack.
And...
What else can we build at the science station?
A whirley fan.
To create some breeze.
Oh, an umbrella.
I almost got lost as well.
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
Yeah, I almost got lost as well.
You can build gold tools.
Ooh.
Wait, it's on the map of the fire pit?
Or the science station?
Oh, it is.
Should I make a shower?
A what? A shower?
A shower.
Oh, a shovel.
Yeah, not a shower.
We don't need a shower.
We're fine.
Okay, I'll make a shower just in case.
Okay.
We have something we could maybe dig.
Is this rope? What can we do with rope?
We found a beef.
I wonder where the spiders are.
Yeah, where's all the spiders you guys talked about?
Yeah, where's all the spiders?
Because if we find spiders, we can get like...
spider glands and then make like
healing stuff
with it. Oh, really?
Yeah.
So that's like a big reason why I want to
find that.
I forgot about healing, to be honest here.
Let me eat the petals I have.
And the berries.
I need to eat my carrot.
Oh, speed.
I'm just gonna eat freaking ice
because I have nothing else to eat.
Okay.
Skinny core.
You need legend?
You want to lose weight?
Just go here in the forest.
Skinny legend another time.
It's true.
It is.
Do you have twigs?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, yeah. Hold on.
Hold on, let me bring my torch out.
You need
twigs,
right? Yes.
Okay, here.
Thank you.
So that way I can...
Wait!
We need to make traps, right?
How do we make one?
Oh, no, you're hungry.
Oh, I am.
I didn't notice.
I'm gonna have some seeds.
I can eat, I can eat.
Hold on.
My torch fucking died.
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
I don't see anything.
Not like this.
No, no.
I can't make a campfire.
No!
We were doing so...
We were doing so fucking good.
What the fuck?
Not like this.
Did you not see that monster right next to us?
I didn't.
I was trying to...
I was basically trying to
make a torch,
but I didn't have enough.
Oh, I didn't have enough
for any...
I might have had enough for a torch.
You gave me your sticks, right?
That's probably why.
We got three days.
That's really good.
Well, technically four.
It's just day four.
Well, I can hunt things.
I've never been a ghost before.
It's always been you that turned into a ghost.
I can hunt the crow!
Oh no, I can't.
Do you see these monsters or is it just me?
This one?
Like the shadow one?
Yeah, I can see those.
Fuck!
I could have saved you if I had enough
for a fucking torch.
Fuck my life.
Wait!
I'm so mad at myself right now.
It's okay.
You know why?
I'm mad at myself because
I have a fucking
lighter that I could have fucking used.
And I
forgot that I have a lighter,
so I could have just
you know, equipped my lighter
and everything would have been fine.
But I forgot that I fucking had one.
Fuck!
No!
We're doing so fucking good.
Wait.
I'm lowering icy sanity
just by being near you.
I better get a heart for Emmy.
A heart?
Okay.
Well, I'll restart it again.
Because I'm at 10 health as well.
It's over.
It's okay.
Every time we die, we learn more
and we become stronger.
Real.
Do you think we will be able
to survive at least like
10 days?
No.
Yeah.
I was hoping you would be like really hopeful
Hell yeah!
It's like no more.
No hope.
Zero hope.
No.
Oh my god.
I think we can make it to like
six though.
Okay, let's see.
Let's take it step by step.
Maybe once we make it to day six
your confidence will boost up
and then
you can be like okay maybe now
I believe we can make it to day ten.
We'll see.
You're like no.
I don't think so.
It's okay. I have enough hope
for the both of us.
If you don't believe in it, I will.
Okay, thank you.
Yes.
I'm gonna become smarter
and work on my reflexes
to turn my lighter on
as soon as we need it.
So we don't die next time.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm still waiting for the game to load.
I think it might have... oh no, okay.
I'll invite you.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna get more water.
Okay.
I was gonna say five, but sure.
This is a good call.
Wow, Snowberry is not believing in me either.
What the heck?
Did you forget
how powerful I am?
I am manifesting right now
that me and Emi
survived for ten days in this game.
I am a manifesting queen.
This will happen.
This will happen
tonight.
All of you non-believers.
Yeah.
I'm gonna prove you wrong.
You're gonna see
how powerful we are
together.
What do you mean?
I'm believing right here.
Okay, that's good.
We're face-maxing.
Oh my god.
The frog not in my guard.
Oh my god, I hate the frog.
OOP.
Like, damn.
This is almost as powerful as the frog.
It's gonna be easy.
I really need to keep organizing
my inventory in a way
that I can see where my important
items are.
That's one of the stuff that keeps
being a problem for me in the game.
I literally had a lighter.
I could've saved us right there
in no moment.
Sounds like
punishment.
The frogs make you drop
your items. Wait, really?
Like, if they attack you
or if I just see them.
She was literally a feral cop.
How could she not make it in the wild?
Come on guys, have some faith.
Okay, exactly.
Remember.
I...
I'm a feral cop. I can survive this.
I went...
I went through worse.
I'm still confused.
What does the teddy bear
do exactly?
I remember we got animated
at a higher setting.
That's almost good.
I'm back.
I'm trying to look at my skills
and figure out if I can learn
something useful.
Oh, true.
I didn't even look at that.
Oh, I'm going to do that
and increase my lighter's brightness.
You can do that?
Yeah.
If you go to skills, you can see
if there's a skill that you would like to learn.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, so that's the one I chose.
Are you in the game yet?
Yes, I'm in the game.
Okay, I'm going to join you soon.
Hello.
Okay, I believe.
I believe.
Every character has a different perk tree.
I know that.
I didn't know there were skills.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Let's see what happens if I touch a beehive.
Oh, God.
I don't think anything could happen.
You think I'll die?
It's buzzing with activity.
That's all that happened.
Nothing happened.
See, bees are friends.
Bee for when?
Bumblebees are so cute.
They're so fluffy.
I'm scared of bumblebees.
I'm scared of all bees.
Look, that guy is getting attacked by spiders.
Wait, they're spiders?
Yeah, over there.
On the other side of the...
Oh, he's gone now.
On the other side of the river,
some pig man was being attacked by a bunch of spiders.
If you press the other button, you punch them.
I want to punch them.
Punch the bees!
Yeah.
That's so cute.
No, nothing happens.
You can't punch the bees.
I'm running away. I don't trust this.
I have a good feeling about this.
You don't trust me near the beehive?
No.
I don't.
I'm trying to be as careful as I possibly can right now.
We made so much progress.
We did.
It's okay.
We'll be able to do it.
What is all of this?
Plants? Examine plants?
It's a plant.
And the frogs are attacking me now.
This whole place is full of frogs.
Oh, look!
There's a
a stage here?
Something's odd here, but I can't put my finger on it.
Ow!
Where are you?
I found a table with
a plant vase
with a flower.
Hold on, let me see.
I'm on my way.
How do you get there?
Go up.
Okay.
Oh, it's roses that have
spines.
Oh.
Look at this.
Cute.
And then every time you pick a flower, you get hurt.
Ow!
Yeah.
Every time you pick a flower, you get hurt.
What is eye bone?
That's all that happens.
What the heck is an eye bone?
Eye bone?
What is that? Chester?
Chester?
Where did we?
How did we get so lucky as to acquire a Chester?
What the heck?
That's so cute.
We should totally build like our thing here
once we find gold.
Yeah. Wait, so can we use Chester?
They found Chester.
Hi, Chester.
Is he going to follow one of us?
Is he following you?
Chester kind of looks like a...
He's following you.
No, he's just...
No, he's following you.
Oh.
You got a Chester.
He looks like a pin pal.
He should be following you.
He does a little bit, yeah.
I like the pumpkin part of it.
I see picked up a bone with an eye
that controls Chester.
Oh!
Hold on.
You take it because it looks like a pin pal.
Okay. Thank you.
And I have my teddy bear.
My snow berry.
Yay!
That's so cute! I love that.
We got our little mascots
with us now.
Yes.
Cute.
You have enough to make a campfire
or no?
I have a torch just in case.
No.
I don't,
because I haven't found any...
I haven't found any flint at all.
Oh.
I only have like one.
Oh, one is enough to make a axe.
Do you have twigs?
Uh...
I do have twigs.
I have six twigs.
You should be able to make an axe
with one flint.
Yeah, I don't have an axe.
Okay.
And then you can build a campfire
with the wood,
the logs.
Okay, let me try this.
Yes, please, please, absolute...
Oh!
You can make torches and just light trees on fire
to have light during the night.
Okay.
I'm walking around.
How did I not find a single flint?
I don't know.
That makes me kind of sad
because we have that great area
that has a bunch of it.
Fuck!
Yeah.
So much.
It was so much stuff.
And now we have nothing.
Now we're in the shitty fucking map again.
What a fucked up day.
It's okay.
We can make this.
I'm sure we'll find a good area eventually.
Oh, we can burn the trees for flints.
Really?
Apparently.
Okay.
Let's just burn this whole part down.
Let's go.
Yay!
Yeah, arson.
And now we don't even...
We don't even need to have a campfire
because we have all this.
Yeah, exactly.
This is our campfire.
It is.
Oh shit! Chester!
Chester!
No!
Please don't tell me he's gonna die.
Please, Chester, please!
He dies!
Okay, he's okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, okay, he's fine.
He's okay.
And that pin fells.
I was just dying just now.
And it was my fault too.
Again.
Oh no.
Oh, can you cut down the trees?
Oh fuck!
My torch is dying!
My torch is on 9%.
Okay.
I really need to remember that I have a fucking lighter.
I keep forgetting.
That's fucking stupid.
Okay, where's my damn axe?
I was so scared for Chester.
Oh, here's charcoal.
Did you get any flint from the trees?
Not really.
All I'm getting is charcoal.
What about you?
I can't cut down the trees because I don't have an axe.
Oh.
What do you need again?
Flint.
You lied to me.
I only have one.
Pin fells, you lied to me and said that I can burn the trees down to get...
Oh no.
How could you?
Oh.
Only petrified trees...
Look at my hat!
Where'd you get that hat from?
I...
It was this...
I saw it blunt to him.
So I picked it up.
Oh damn.
Hopefully it's not haunted.
Yeah, I hope so.
I don't...
It must not be good for your sanity till we're dead people's clothes, is it?
Uh...
My sanity is okay right now.
Okay.
Insight games?
There's all the flint cut things.
I know, right? There's none.
Yeah, like what the fuck?
How? Like...
Huh?
How are...
There's really none.
How are they...
How are we supposed to get any further in the game?
Any further in the game if there's no torches or no...
Bad starting biome.
I think...
From what I'm looking at the map, we should probably go all the way up again.
Okay.
Because there's like water surrounding us and nowhere for us to like...
process.
I'm going up. Okay.
Yeah, me too.
Certain biomes are more likely to have a flint on the ground.
Grassy areas or maybe rocky areas.
There's grass everywhere.
Okay, keep going up.
Whoa! Oh no, I found a spider den.
I should have been the spider.
Fuck.
Do you think if I get close to it, they'll attack me?
I don't know.
Probably safe to not get close to it.
Fuck, I'm so tempted.
I know, right? Like what's going to happen?
I think they're just going to chase us.
But maybe we could kill them.
Because we would...
I don't have a weapon.
Okay, true. Let's wait until you have your own weapon.
Okay, okay.
Trying to find fucking flint in this shitty area.
Oh, evil flower.
I have an evil flower.
Why can't I pick up the blue mushroom?
Fuck. Oh, there's a question mark up there.
What the hell? What is this?
Swap clothes, mannequin.
Did you find it?
A mannequin?
Yeah, look at this area.
She's got cute clothes on.
Oh my god, look! Look, I'm wearing her clothes.
Oh, wait, that's kind of scary.
What?
Hell yeah.
Must defend safe.
What are they talking?
I need to make...
Should I set a campfire here?
Yeah, yes, yes.
Not yet though.
But be ready to...
I'm getting...
Can we interact with this stuff?
A village, there's a village.
You can take my hat.
Sure, I'll take the hat.
Careful, careful, careful.
They don't like us being near that thing for some reason.
Examine stage, perform!
It's a setup, it feels too staged.
Oh fuck.
Should we... Is there a village here?
There's like more stuff.
There's flowers?
Oh, those are really quick.
Oh, find a path maybe?
Let's just keep running.
Okay, let's maybe...
I didn't know that would happen.
Same.
There's stuff on the floor, spider gland.
Oh, they're still coming!
Oh fuck.
Maybe if I put a campfire, it'll make them go away?
No.
They just want to chew on the campfire.
Fuck.
Wait, I think we're good now.
Are we?
No, no, no, no.
Fuck, I don't have my weapons.
Oh!
No, no!
No, I got a spider in my ass too, no.
No, I got multiple spiders in my ass.
And I don't have my weapons.
Wait, why do I have an axe?
Did you give me your axe?
Oh wait, they're eating the spider.
They're fighting against each other.
The spider and the flower thing?
They're fighting.
Thank god.
Who's winning?
I don't know.
What's that on the floor?
Crack-crack-dull mask.
Oh look, now we're matching!
Cute!
Oh my god.
Okay.
They're eating Chester?
Wait, but Chester's okay.
Okay.
I want to go back to that place though.
Me too.
Careful, there's spiders.
Oh fuck.
What the fuck is that?
Why are there so many jump scares in this game?
Oh my god.
Why are there so many?
Come on, I just want it to be like again.
Come on!
Come back, son.
You can use that to break down trees for logs?
Oh, you're getting the logs.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm going to use my lighter.
That's helpful.
Do we?
Oh fuck.
Oh no!
Go away!
We can use it to break more trees, I guess.
Oh fuck!
Come over here, break these trees down for us.
Wait, can it break down this?
Oh fuck!
It got trampled!
It's okay.
I wanted to break down the spiders.
Break down the spiders stuff.
Okay, how?
I don't think it's able to.
Is it able to?
Maybe.
I'm not sure.
Careful when you walk on the webs.
The spiders come out.
Oh wait.
Is it silk?
Got it.
Are all the spiders dead?
I can light the spider den on fire!
Yes!
Perfect!
I really need your fire.
I can light the pig house on fire too!
Oh man.
This was a rough night.
It was, but it was a fun night.
That thing is still walking around too.
Oh god.
I have like...
There's monster meat.
Oh, you can use spider glands to heal yourself.
Yeah.
There's a monster meat.
Oh fuck.
What is this on the four ashes?
Ashes?
There's an interesting thing over here.
Okay.
Oh god, not this guy again.
It's okay.
He's friendly.
No, it says it's nasty.
I think I need to cool it.
Don't break the den.
Don't burn it.
Oh fuck.
It's okay, it's okay.
I just wanted to pick up the stuff he has.
He's really easy to avoid, it's okay.
I'll put some stuff in Chester.
Oh.
I got a backpack.
Okay, that's good too.
Wait, how do you have a backpack?
Ah, because I found one laying here.
Oh, you found a laying.
I guess you could use Chester as your backpack.
Yeah, I can.
So I'm guessing this is the village.
Ah, so...
How do you cook meat, by the way?
You have to cook it on the campfire.
You back off, that's my space.
I don't like it when you enter their village, I guess.
Willow is immune to fire damage and overheat slowly.
Yes, yes.
I wonder how much meat we would get
if we both attacked one of the pigs.
Do you want to?
I want to try,
but I'm also scared because there's a lot of them.
Oh, I do have an axe.
Do you think they'll all come running after us
if we attack one?
I mean, definitely.
They're running after us even like
we don't do anything to them.
Oh, do you think if we give them meat,
they'll be friendly?
I don't know.
Why is this one not attacking?
I don't think I'll stay away.
I don't know.
What if I give them meat?
Time for food, meat hungry.
Too close.
You have meat, you're not pig.
You're not pig.
Well, damn.
Let me try killing this frog.
Come here, frog.
I want to try giving them meat
and seeing what happens.
I gave to one of them meat.
Oh, that's probably why they're not attacking anymore.
Okay.
Home time.
Scary.
What happened to the tree?
Can we go inside one of their houses?
I don't know.
Me tree berries.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay, where is my...
Oh, no, this guy is stuck.
He can't go inside a house.
There's a guy over here.
Oh, no.
I mean, now it seems okay.
It's just like Minecraft villagers.
Bro, just walk inside the house.
Why are you...
He's stupid. He doesn't know what he's doing.
Okay.
There's this thing.
Oh, my God, they have a head on a stick.
Wait, what?
They have a head on a stick
in the village.
Wait, let me see.
Look at it.
Oh.
That's what you get for being so stinky.
What is a worm for?
A worm.
Examine headstone.
It says calm on in.
Okay.
In the fucking grave.
In the grave? Probably.
It's inviting us to die, probably.
It says I was underground
before it was a thing.
What does that supposed to mean?
Before it was a thing.
I wanted to die before it was cool.
Oh, my God.
Let's...
Let's keep exploring
because I literally haven't found
a single piece of flint yet.
Right? How do I get...
How do I make a fucking...
Yeah, fucking flint.
I'm baffled that there's still no fucking flint.
Like, how does that happen?
I really need food.
Meat.
Nah, I'm okay on food right now.
How much is your hunger?
It says 69%.
Yeah, you should...
You should find the light green area
for flint or rock area.
Okay.
Let me look at the map.
Damn it, I really should have been spider person.
Maybe if we die again,
you could try that.
Yeah, next time.
I think if we go right...
I think if we go right,
I see rocky area.
So, let's keep going
and then when it gets dark, we can set up a campfire.
Okay.
You have the tools to make one, right?
Yeah, I do.
Oh, wait, I want to get this musher.
Okay.
Just for fun.
Spiders are your friend.
Campfire time, campfire time.
Okay, come on.
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
If spiders are friends with you,
it doesn't mean they're...
Wait, if spiders are friends with you,
it doesn't mean they're friends with your friend.
Oh!
What?
So, they would still attack Icy?
Really?
Oh, no.
The poor guy.
His name is Eggie.
Is that all?
Dude, I think Eggie is going to die.
Why?
He's all alone.
Is he hungry?
Eggie.
Oh, I shouldn't go there.
I don't know.
He's all alone over there.
Okay, there we go.
That was fast.
What?
Ah, fuck any of the pickaxes.
So fucking bad.
Like, please, give me a fucking flint.
I know.
Okay, I'm still going down this way.
Following the path.
Okay, I'll go with you.
Okay.
At least I thought this dark area was rock.
But maybe it's not?
Oh, maybe this isn't rock.
Whoa, did you see that coming out of the ground?
Wet tentacles?
What the fuck?
Oh, no.
Okay, let's go.
Wow.
I don't trust you.
I don't think we'll get any...
I don't think we'll get flint here,
but I thought that was cool.
Okay.
I am...
Like, how is there no flint still,
like, this entire time?
It just doesn't make any sense to me.
Okay.
They said it's the most hostile area of the game,
so we should avoid it.
Oh, look, another one.
This time it's got the king mask.
Ooh.
And a king costume.
And then I absolutely should not
attack the flowers.
Now I'm the king.
Oh, wait a minute.
Safe king.
I protect king.
Wait a minute.
What he hit me in one hit he killed me in one oh we can just reset the world
that's helpful yeah we should just die together huh yeah next time we can just
die together and that's easier reset now do it yeah that's the first we've got
two so far I'm aiming for 10 I'm aiming for 10 I'm aiming for six and you could
be at the spider now as well yeah I wanted to try that I want to see if
there's any other skills I can upgrade where did you see the upgrade yeah it's
in the skill set like you click the character and then click skill set on
the bottom right
does anyone know how to use Bernie like my teddy bear or like what does he do
when you go insane you drop him he comes to life the teddy bear comes to
life yeah when my sanity when I go insane what what does he do when like he
comes to life you can put the bear on the ground and it'll transform and attack
demons I'm here you look surprisingly cute I'm so cute look at me wow I love
you in your spider form I have I have spiders that's actually adorable I love
your expression oh I can plant my friends on the ground somewhere okay I won't
plant them yet wait what how's Bernie doing good how do I see my own skills
again I don't remember how to do that from this menu oh I found it no no I
didn't okay okay let's let's see what we can do
wait this is this world similar to is this the same world or no a low-key kind
of feels like it but I don't think so I don't remember this like look I don't
remember seeing this maybe not hopefully there's actual flint in here in this
freaking map here's the light grass area they said light grass would have
me too we're saved okay no nice nice wait so does this character also only eat
meat I don't know it's how you can eat everything okay good good
they added a lot to this game I only remember playing it when it like first
came out and I didn't play much yeah hmm there's fog over here really I'm on my
way I'm trying to pick up everything I found a piece of cold you can also eat
food that normally has a bad effect like monster me hey let's go oh yeah I
remember trying to eat it but it was like oh I can make a pickaxe and mind this you
can okay good yes hell yeah we are already on the better start I can make a
pickaxe too nice I'll do it I'll make an axe yes I found one gold let's go okay this
is already so much better than the previous one it is I'm mining too now yeah and I found
night or night or night or night sure I don't know but I found that too yeah oh this one has
gold I think okay okay I have a much better feeling about this one me too oh there's a crab
in the water there's lots of things in the water I wonder if there's a way to like walk into the
water like if there's anything we can craft or build we need a bolt you found it there's
a bolt kids but it says you need so probably some sort of words oh you need a sorry you cut out
what I need a few logs okay okay but it says use a science machine to build a prototype
that's okay we can do that I can I have enough for a science mission I think just need more wood
is it harder for me to cut down trees because I'm a spider or something I've been having so
much trouble cutting down trees I got a science machine okay I'm gonna make our base here and I'm
gonna I'm gonna plant down the spider eggs I have but I'll put them further away just in case they
attack you you can you can plant spider eggs yeah I'm gonna put them right here wait do they not
get planted what do I do plant there we go I don't know I think I can hurt them I don't know
what that means oh shoot I'm so sorry I hope they don't attack you what does it mean to hurt them
oh I blow the whistle and then they do what they come to me
okay thank you nice okay uh let me oh my god the spiders keep scaring me let me look
at the how do I look at the research oh there we go um you said bolt is it in fishing I don't know
that doesn't tackle receptacle fishing rod fishing bin will they attack I see I don't
know we're about to find out they've been walking around but they haven't attacked her okay I can
work boats are see do you do you have grass yeah yeah thank you oh fuck I need I need three
more grass so I can make a grass raft kit oh three more okay let's go sailing yeah it will be nice
to check out stuff in the water mm-hmm there's like eyes on the in the box you're getting
I was too but I actually had some gamers
oh yeah it helped wake me up a bit cuz I was really sleepy as well like before we
when started the stream I was like yawning non-stop mm-hmm gamer so I'm surprised I thought it was it
just like gatorade it doesn't have caffeine in it doesn't it depends they have decaf and they have
ones that do have caffeine oh I had one with caffeine so I can you know wake up a bit
like sleepy as fuck like which one was your favorite flavor um to be honest I'm I'm not
I haven't tried all the flavors I tried shy lilies one and I tried the purple lean mm-hmm I like
both of them I think they're both nice flavors I haven't tried I haven't tried shy lilies one yet
which one did you try I tried guacamole gamer farts and lean did you like the lean the lean is
okay I liked it guacamole gamer farts tastes like shit but it's the taste reminds me of
um of like strawberry kiwi Kool-Aid and I never liked that flavor of Kool-Aid so yeah that's an
interesting flavor yeah that's what it reminds me of a tub of anime girl thigh coming in today
come on I'm coming please please please die yes yes come on oh he's too fast
also there's a sinkhole here um I don't know if you want to oh wait I might have lost it
oh here it is if you want to go in there should why is there a bunch of bats around us what
happened huh I don't know spiders help me spiders please why are they coming
where where even where even is our base okay I think I think they're living you alone okay I
think I see it up here what happened to my minions guys come on you you're really bad at your job
really useless like I'm for nothing what are they doing nothing cuz they're he's literally
looking so scared at everything I know every time I press the herd the herd of spiders
but nothing happens am I doing this wrong I thought if I press the herd spiders button
they would come and help me they're just walking around I don't want to like nah I'm good I'm good
I don't want to deal with that shit you can I still have no grass oh what's that oh I couldn't find
any grass either we really need to get on the boat look at this thing should we attack attack
attack attack attack attack yes we got to meet on the spiders helped attack to
oh it's getting dark okay no no don't come towards me don't
okay I couldn't even eat my meat in peace oh I forgot that I I'm supposed to eat food
oops I I have been starving no how hungry are you can I cook carrots I can maybe yeah I would
yeah I can and berries you can cook berries attack them attack them attack them they're
attacking me back can you be like a cannibal and cook their meat and eat it I have five
help left yes I'm eating now nice cannibalism let's go okay there's something we can make to heal
I'm gonna try and kill him be careful come here okay come on come on come on come on come on
come on healing gloop gloop healing block I thought I could kill him on my own because I'm stupid as
okay yes my gift please be something to heal me please be something to heal me okay a
pantomimed pickaxe I can't even use it now I have to use it later
okay um we just need to pick a bunch of flowers I think we should go pick flowers to see
how do we craft like something to heal the the stuff to heal um we need silk and honey I think
and ashes and we don't have any of that fuck this gay earth the mushroom here yeah I think
that mushroom is gonna be the death I fucking knew it I was like I ain't eating that mushroom it's
just gonna bring bad news and then you eat it then you fucking die someone told me that I could eat
things that would normally not be edible so I did pain pals it just fucking tried to get you
killed oh my god you told me that I could have was that five days survived three days oh fuck not
even five let's restart let's restart okay kill yourself that's a good question yeah let's go
let's let's go on a only generally asking the important question we gotta go on an adventure to
find out how to kill you yeah I need to find something that will attack me I suppose they said
fight another otter I don't know where they are or maybe the spiders maybe my spiders can kill you
are we far we're kind of oh that mushroom heals if eaten cooked damages if eaten wrong oh
oh I can well that would have been nice to know before
oh that thing oh that's a piece of driftwood never mind oh maybe I can push it closer to you
I push the I wonder I think I can
I can push it towards you
she get driftwood yeah what do I do with it though I said perfect for burning so
I thought I can use it to kill myself let's see are my spider here come attack the spiders
there's one here okay come here bitch kill me you've been wanting to come on okay bye
oh look at us we look so cute as ghosts
the cutest ghost ever there's the fucking otter
can I hold my spider and walk around is it no oh
what did I do to my spider um I thought oh let me see is that just me when I haunted it it
it's it changed it looks different see look now it looks different I think I'm just going crazy I
don't know but let's reset the the world do it okay okay this is my last attempt this is my
last ditch effort okay okay let's attempt okay okay we can do it yeah losing sanity
IRL okay for real the sanity in game is always okay but IRL no it's just fucking terrible
um okay oh boy should I should I go with willow again
oh I was willow no you were oh sorry wilson wilson wilson I mean whatever is most fun for
you to play with gentlemen scientists you know I'll go with the spider actually no the spiders
we're attacking you I'll go with wilson okay pick when do you do yourself a favorite well it's
too late I already chose wilson it's it's over it's okay fuck it's okay we'll make it to five days
we'll make it to five days one day we will we will become pros at this game I just know it
you're like no we won't
I mean it's fun to die this game has so many creative ways to kill yourself
it really does yeah it's fun okay I'm gonna pick up lots of grass because apparently
we were lacking in that last time juicy berries ooh there's a frog here I have to be careful
kissing your sister oh turkey jumped out kissing your sister simulator
that's just every stream of mine
oh my god shebe's in there oh my god can we can we cool car
can we eat lots of meat on her oh yeah she does yeah she really especially all those
thighs imagine that's me juicy I hope shebe's not listening right now
she told she told me that she lurks in your streams so I hope she's not here oh boy
oh there's a green mushroom there's things over here there's more marble marble sculptures
oh that's interesting what do they do I don't know
oh
interesting they don't do anything I guess they're just there
is this supposed to be some sort of lore I wonder if it's like lore some kind of puzzle even
but I'm too stupid for puzzles so I wouldn't fucking get it all I'm too stupid for puzzles and the lore
oh there's no sticks though
oh I hate the sound of the bees
lore for boss fight oh there's boss fights
we're dying from like the bare minimum and they put boss boss fights in this game
I thought I thought we were seeing the bosses already I thought we were meeting the bosses
oh there's sticks get those ones that's the only I'm kind of concerned because they didn't find
like any food yet oh never mind there's a carrot here okay I'm concerned because I can't find sticks
I have four twigs I think
um keep those I think I can find some oh I found some already
I got an x2 okay good
I think the bosses are I have HP bars all it's in late game
you've only seen five percent of the game
what the fuck and that's how bad we are is there a final boss
that'd be cool
cool
is there an ender dragon of of don't starve
you're not chin
oh berry bush oh wait we did that one
there's one
it's crazy how much there is in this game but we're so bad that like well they spend like five percent
what the fuck well we're noobs we're noobs
we're learning why doesn't
what's this walk to burrow
hold me hold on the ground oh maybe we use shovels to um to get into the burrows
oh my god oh look there's something on the floor there
suspicious marble oh that thing is heavy
do you want to oh I wonder if we need to put one of those marbles on one of those things
like put it uh where the statues are yeah where even are they
I'm sorry oh there's more I found another one it makes me so fucking slow
look how fucking slow I am holy fuck you're right I have one too I'm carrying one too
oh bro
is it worth it no fuck it I'm dropping it I am not dealing with this shit
too slow can't get anything done like this
whoa there's a gigantic beehive
really yeah well there's so many flowers in here
oh yeah there are and also lots of bees
oh god oh go away
oh shit oh where are you oh there you are my lighter I'm here I'm here okay I have my lighter on
okay okay okay
ah I got a lot of flowers so if we ever if we get hurt we can eat those um should I make a campfire
yeah sure I have stuff to cook nice there has to be a way to get honey without killing
killing the bees I wonder
lay it on fire
oh you're not wrong
I'm gonna I'm gonna try lighting the big the big one on fire
okay can I cook a cook grass add fuel no I didn't know
um
the snow bears need to carry it for her yes snow bears I need you to carry all these marbles
for us because you are strong and powerful bears you can you can carry it for both of us
please do it yes be really useful please do it for us pretty please
um will that give me honey you think I don't know why what the fuck are these things
you it's the bees
I burnt down their home and I'm gonna go burn down their other homes
I wonder if I use a torch against them if they will die fast I can't burn it it doesn't let me
I can't burn the big one dear you guys just smack it with a hammer I don't know if I want to
I'm burning this one though because these holes are mean yeah why won't they let me
be
I'll try thank you good job good job good job good job that's what they deserve that's what
they deserve yes that's what you get for being mean to us yeah
so well can we get honey from this
um no we can just get like ashes dang it
oh we tried yeah we oh look another suspicious marble statue yeah come on snow
barriers help pick this up oh fuck okay I like that one better too okay
oh god that's a fucking frog stay away from me
I can light up this one as well right yeah go ahead careful
because they're gonna chase you I got too cocky I got too cocky oh fuck
are you getting chased by the frogs and the bees oh it's oh fuck I need sticks to make an axe
I don't have an axe oh no I do have an axe never mind I got an axe I'll save you please kill the
frogs oh the frogs and the bees are fighting never mind oh thank god okay just go fight
I hate how many bees are here oh my god I cannot enjoy anything in this area what the fuck
oh okay it shows on the map where the is there a way to like get the
there there's no way that they expect us to walk every statue back to the that that statue um
like formation right I wonder if like maybe you're supposed to like build something to like
carry it or something yeah that's why there's so many frogs in here what the there is a lot
like yeah because there's blank spaces so they probably expect you to bring those statues back
oh wait and then it's probably a boss battle it'll probably spawn a boss
yeah we are not ready for a boss a boss battle a boss battle a boss battle
oh look there's paper on the floor oh there's other stuff on the floor can I eat the rot
okay yeah I eat the rot ew
we can cook stuff in here oh we can cook stuff in here that's awesome that's so helpful cook
oh there's like shit it's not working wait can you use your lighter to light it
there we go I wonder is it cooking I think so let me see
any ham oh that's like a recipe oh where's my here here's a cookbook oh and that's the ham recipe
oh there's a and here's my lighter
oh no did you just like the crackpot on fire yeah because I thought I'm supposed to do that for it to
cook I thought so too um I thought so too um um
you're supposed to do it like that's the logical thing to do like light the pot right like cool
I know I agree I thought the same thing wait why did I get a fist full of jam now okay
oopsies the crackpot got cooked
oh my god oh shit my my berries went spoiled I feel so bad about what the fuck I'm gonna just leave
I really thought I'm doing something you really thought you ate yeah I really thought I ate with
I was like yeah I know what I'm doing let me cook and then I just cook the entire pot itself
and burn it there's nothing fucking there's nothing like it left I should not be cooking
okay and then light anything on fire that's okay we'll find we'll find another one I'm sure
we'll make one we'll make one we just need um oh there's a turkey where
I think he hit somewhere oh they can hide in the berry bushes
it won't let me examine the berry bush
this bush is working hard on the next batch wait I wonder if I set it on fire if he will come out
do you think that would work try okay let me smell it
no I guess not uh I guess he just he went somewhere else teleported somewhere never mind
I guess
oh my inventory is oh oh fuck I don't feel safe that fire is gonna go out um
yeah um uh uh
I have one here you have one wait is there two why is there two
uh because because I didn't realize you were making one wait I did I make that one
my memory is terrible I do not know I don't know either oopsies
don't let me eat the carrots why would I want to spin the carrot what the fuck why am I spinning
the carrot what I thought I could maybe cook the rot but I can't so uh if you want to eat
some rot uh here you go I don't my inventory is full let me uh oh I'm on fire the carrot is
sure here here here um take this jam
okay and these seeds and uh I need I need twigs maybe should we keep the cookbook
I I wonder like I don't know how useful it would be do you think these guys are made out of ham
yes should we take their ham yes
get over here set him on the fire try try try no hit him hit him hit him hit him
get his ham get his ham let's go
okay I'm gonna eat a bunch of flowers because that almost killed me
are you very hungry no I'm just almost dead oh no well the cook meat should probably give you
some health right I don't know well I guess try it here okay
it I think it gave me a little bit take all the petals I have and eat them thank you how's your
health my health is good it's pretty full pretty much okay okay well dang we stole his ham and I ate
it and now we have no um ham to make the recipe do you have flint
yes I have one yeah could you give me what I need to I need to make an axe
thank you
but I think we're running into the same problem as before where I can't find a I can't find flint
yeah we're just asking each other I can't find any flint
yeah we should probably like go somewhere let me see should probably explore areas we haven't been
to yet on the map yeah um
let's just go down maybe yeah I was thinking the same
there might just be more um oh it's just water they're mine wow
wow
okay well let's go up I guess
one less tree in the world we're just deforesting this whole area yeah we are there's a dead guy
oh look he has a spear through his skull I didn't notice that
I thought maybe I could take it but I guess not
bow
let me steal his let me steal his spear
are you listening to music oh wait I shouldn't let them hit me I'm almost dead already
oh fuck oh fuck yeah yeah keep running keep running I am I'm out I have 35 health
is a pink green mushroom healthy should I cook it last time it was a red one that killed me
whoa look at that what the fuck is that is that a rabbit oh maybe it's a rabbit in the ground yeah
watch a tentacle come out of oh it's a mole oh cute oh they're so cute I love them
can I kill it I have a plushie of one you have more plushie yes
it doesn't like when I click it like nothing happened oh there's like a flower here maybe
it doesn't want to come out of the ground for me to kill it
oh there's a bunch of moles around here look at them they're everywhere
so there's like nothing around here
chat can I eat pink green mushrooms
and and and if she can't let us know if she needs to cook them first
yes please please be specific if you're brave enough what
it senses the death that me was about to give oh that's why the moles don't want to come out to meet me
they know what's gonna happen yeah then oh great another dead dead fucking end
I guess let's go this way okay there's more flower here
I'll try to eat the flowers
that's why I'm really cute
and we're struggling yeah we are
hey the ceasefire is not coming
there's no flint and it's another dead end
what are you scared of dying I want to make it to at least day five
uh what day are we on now we're on day three three oh we'll make it
yeah we'll make it to day five we will
uh we've we've we've done better and died faster
does your later die ever yeah it does but not anytime soon I suppose
okay it doesn't have it lasts it lasts a pretty long time okay like a mole came to say hi
oh
hello I just discovered feel learn I love it I hope you're you I hope you're all doing well and great
welcome
um I think a lot of people um when they first heard about velour they expected us to be like
jorking it on youtube yeah that's that's exactly that every stream is a jorking stream
clap clap clap on youtube
the mushrooms have to be cooked okay I'll cook them
wait it's not no
oh wait what do you mean what's not it's not a jorking stream
uh shocking
shocking how dare they how dare they advertise themselves how dare they not jerk off right now
exactly also people were um in the clip where I showed like a a little bit of boobage people
were mad because I didn't show enough boob yeah I did say I did say that I would only show a little
but um they didn't realize how little meant I said a little a little is a little you got a little
you're welcome I thought a little is like three one minute they thought a little was like whole nip
they thought a little they thought a little bit was like I'm gonna take my shirt off completely and
and slap them onto the desk
oh my god
it was absolutely worth the money okay I'm glad that you think it was worth it because
you were the one that gave it but um but some of the comments look yeah that's funny the people
that didn't even the people that didn't donate the money were the ones that were the most pissed
that I didn't show enough what happens all the time the people who don't you know
like pay for it are the ones that always usually like complain uh-huh uh-huh yeah like you're just
watching the clip you weren't there why are you so mad why are you mad because the comments were like
for four hundred dollars I could get real tits and I could do more than just look at them
yeah remember that oh my god look at these well go ahead and do that yeah go ahead use
the use your own four hundred and and go find some real tits stop it you let your life to the
fullest do it um yeah yeah do it if you want go ahead but my tits my tits are special
they are oh thank you they look very nice
you look nice too
oh
sex collabs two people thought we would have sex
oh real life sex collapse
I'm sorry if we disappointed you with no off collab sex yeah sorry
we're just retombing unsubbed
looking forward to the meet and greet oh yeah meet and greet where we where we uh we oh
shit I jumped in a wormhole okay I'm gonna jump as well okay
okay maybe we'll find something better in this area I don't think there's anything better in this
area be careful what is that this area is what the fuck
get on the path you walk faster on the path you walk faster on the path okay okay okay
look at this boulder I wonder why it has I need I need two flints I can't I don't have a pickaxe
oh yeah I did not see a flint in the wild
you're telling me you don't want to kiss your homies Amy um
I kiss my homies as long as they're wearing socks and we say no homo afterwards
I really want to see what's in this folder it looks special oh no this is just a rough it's not
oh flint over here oh okay okay okay I'm more more let's go yes yes okay I'm gonna make a pick
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna open that rock okay spread it open right now
I'm doing it what is this moon rock oh we can use it for a moon ritual
uh let me plant some trees I guess
not okay now we can we can get cool and make that uh
bite it and make the the the sides table yeah that's true okay I should get a pickaxe as well why
yes I have poop
yeah and what are we gonna do with that do you want my poop um thank you but I'm good
I appreciate the thought though oh look at this thing
clockwork night clock I'm oh god please no no I'm I'm good it's got no it's got no um
oh the floor I can mine this thing really keep it distracted keep it distracted keep it
at the keep oh I set him on fire oh I set him on fire okay okay okay um
oh shoot I'm okay I have a torch I have a torch no I pressed the wrong button I pressed the wrong
button I didn't mean it how did you die how did you die I ate a red cap
I didn't mean to press it okay keep keep try try breaking the statue see what happens okay
how do I break it do you have a pickaxe I need to set a camp fire first okay I can't I can't
can I hunt that thing you're gonna set a campfire oh fuck oh fuck where's where's my axe
fuck how do I break it that's my fault but I I got too curious I wanted to see what happens
if I open it it's okay I wanted to see his head fell off we were close to day five we got no we
got to day five nice let's go we got to day five it's not day six but no we made it to day five
totally it's day it's day five yeah we did it you know you didn't you died right before day five
yesterday shut up it counts if it says day five that means we made it yeah yeah exactly we made it
we did it no yes you will not say no to me I'm the princess you will say yes for me at all time
listen to Icy she's the one that's right we've made it to day five yes we did let's go okay
I'm gonna move us to the just chatting screen
huh where are you so tiny
I should close the game right yeah yeah yeah yeah I have like Emi taking look we're sitting look
we're sitting on my big chair we are together yeah yeah look I'm sitting together with Emi
I have to find the street
damn it I got an ad
it's okay I'll wait I'll wait I even have hat shockey prepared for you
what's hot chucky hot chocolate oh hot chocolate yeah I call it just hot chucky oh okay okay I was
like hot hot hot chucky oh we're both sitting on the chair oh that's so cute I thought that was
coffee like like a cappuccino I didn't know that was hot chocolate yeah me too cappuccinos are really
except when I visited Europe they made cappuccinos different really how so like all the coffee
was really bitter and not sweet at all really yeah I have a different experience and I literally
live in Europe really do they sell like is it common to sell sweet coffee I literally went to a
dessert truck and I asked for their uh ice cream coffee right which was coffee with ice cream
and they just gave me black coffee with a scoop of ice cream inside what yeah
I would be so mad I was mad I was mad because I was like I'm expecting dessert you just but you
just gave me black coffee that's so weird that's honestly so weird what the heck this is okay
it's okay I didn't pay for it my mom did okay well if you ever come to where I am I'll get you some
actual nice sweet coffee to make up for that experience thank you thank you
scammed for real I did a little bit in the south coffee with sugar is a crime is it a crime
in some places I don't know it's not coffee ice cream it's coffee
ice cream like like the game you just like black coffee and then ice cream like like not to not
not as like a one like dessert thing yeah it's it's coffee period ice cream so like a coffee
float then yeah that's what it sounds like I don't remember what it was called but it was it was
something along the lines of coffee ice cream yeah it was bad and I had trouble finding any
coffee that was sweet even the cat that like the cappuccinos and like um that's so bizarre where
were you in Europe like when that happened I can't say okay but it's close to you
that's why I texted you I was like we should we should go on a date we should we should because
if it's close like no joke I could like literally take a train to where you are and we could like
literally have an off-collapse someday that would be awesome that would be cool I'd have to plan it in
advance but yeah yeah same but it would be cool I'll text you next time ahead and see and see if
what happens that would be so cool oh my god like I would finally have like a friend I around to like
go do stuff where it would be yeah
is anyone um is any other veal or girl streaming right now um I think
Ronnie should be streaming Peggle right yeah she's streaming Peggle we should rate into strong
yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna rate into her as well okay I'll go set that up right now
man rating on YouTube is so much harder than twitch it is yeah it's like I always need to
remember to like do that I was gonna rate her yesterday but like I completely forgot you're
like supposed to go through the settings and then go through customization and then click
like redirect I give us like and then you have to save it and then on twitch you can just type
slash raid and then add username yeah I wish I wish it was this easy on youtube wow
oh
strongy pegging let's go get pegged by strongy
I keep fucking accidentally opening a picture of a really big period blood clot because I sent
it to mimosa during our stream and for some reason my computer saved it I sent it to her
it's not my clot but it's so it's I was telling her a story about clots and now it's like saved to
my um it's saved to my recommended oh my god you know what that reminds me of I was I was crawling
through twitter today and and I saw an ice cream that looked like a period
untwitted yeah yeah I'm scrolling through like that for you and I'm like okay why are you giving
me ice cream that looks like a period pad why is that for me you gotta show that to me I need to
but I don't know if I will is it by magnum I don't know is it because I looked it up and I found
one by magnum really it's like it's like white and then it has like a lot of like red in the middle
yeah yeah it's euphoria and chill is like the name ladies why not treat yourself to a sanitary
pad flavored ice cream I don't think they realized it yeah I think they should uh
reconsider the design of that ice cream and redo it some other way because that looks really bad
that does not look appetizing to me I mean it looks like a clean pad at least
so you can you can you can snack on a clean pad instead of a bloody one like
what is eating eat me that this is your idea of a snack well it's ice cream it's still ice cream
it just looks like a pad
I feel like you have worse food combinations than me no I don't are you kidding me I don't
do those food combinations anymore I used to do that when I was a child but you posted a weird
picture on Twitter like right near debut of like some really strange food combination
oh what that was that was like that was baked chicken and mashed potatoes
hold on and I and I made and I used ketchup because I wanted to draw a heart with it
you put ketchup in mashed potatoes only to make that heart I I tried to like make a heart to make
it super cute and be like here here's your food snowberry but everyone made fun of my cooking
because they put ketchup in mashed potatoes for the art for the heart
but you could have used gravy or did you not have gravy I mean how would I draw a heart with a
gravy that doesn't make sense to me okay but normally I don't put ketchup on my mashed potatoes
okay it was strictly it was strictly so I can draw a heart on the mashed potatoes but it didn't
it ended up looking like not even a heart so yeah don't let Icy cook
she'll put mad she'll put ketchup in your mashed potatoes to show my love to show her love
okay well let's let's let's we can we can end it here thank you thank you for watching
snowberries and and pinpals um thank you for being here I appreciate it we had a lot of fun and I
hope you did as well uh-huh uh-huh I'll be streaming sunday Icy why don't you stream again uh tomorrow
I'm gonna have a member stream tomorrow for a watch along okay okay so there's our next
streams if you want to see them uh yeah that's it thank you for joining us thank you bye
so